相当ごまかしてもすごく全然本当は日本語できないから相当ごまかしてます
道民ですよろしくお願いします普段日本語を全く使っていない日本語の先生がもし友達
の日本語能力を評価したらどうかっていう動画を
今日作ってみたいと思いますそうなんですぼく普段から日本語を使っていないっていう
の家の中ではもうずっと
英語になってるんですよ以前から家を出て別の人他人と a 日本語を話すっていう
機械が全然ないんです
実はかなりええまあいつもと全然打って変わっての動画なっちゃうんですけれどもまあ
それでも
ん
盗んだら今日の動画の watch パンチラインは何かと言いますと
僕です僕がオチなんですっっていうのは
日本語の先生やっているのに日本がおかしいからです
わかりますちなみに今日あって台本がないんでえ
そうなんですかなり緊張してますはいまずはこちらの方上位 adn めめん
僕の友達の多分10年ぐらい前からこの動画をアニメについての動画配信してるんです
けれども彼の日本語を聞いてみましょう
薬価あお前次第はちゃんと埋めとけって思い何回エラーがんだよお前本当に
ん
別の動画にしよう会の皆さんこんばんはこんばんは
僕ですがん僕全然日本語でどうかを取らないんですよまぁ見ての通り見ての通りじゃあ
ね外見だななんかそう思われないのが普通なんですけどまぁ僕は一応ハーフというもの
で以上まいたそだ調査会なんですけど母親が日本人でまぁ今もう日本でを全部英語で
やってるんでまぁ日本にいる視聴
さんがなかなかないということなんですよなんかそれはをし日本に住んでいる日本の
視聴者がなかなかいいないこれははから僕も同じだかこれは惜しいことだと思いまして
この動画を逆みようかなと思います
何をやるかと言いますとまあ定番中の定番ですよこちら秋弁当というまあ前の動画にも
一家や
たことあるんですけどあれは字幕付きでやったんですけどタイマーここまで聞いたら
タブー
皆さんは感情を持っ矢部彼の動画字幕ないんだまあいいや彼の日本はもう完璧です文法
の発音も何もかも完璧ですハーフて
まあ僕の経験からしますと大体どっち寄りになっちゃうっていうか英語
は完璧にできるけど日本語はもう日常会話レベルしかできないとかもしくはその反対
しかし
女医は全く両方完璧に話せるから
a 完璧に話せるだけじゃなくて両方の言語で確か俳優とかもやってるから本当に
すごいと思うんですよね尊敬しちゃうんですが僕もあの
結構ずっと前から日本語で頑張ろうと思ってて
ずっと一生懸命頑張ってるんだけどなかなかここまでいいかないっていうか英語が全く
喋れないっていう状況を作ってみようかなと客に
方にはもう普段から見ている視聴者さんをもうもイギリス阻害するところ思いっきり
吸っまあまあ名言ですねーああいう日本語の動画ってさぁもう
ぜっ
字幕入れなきゃいけないんだよに文具わかる日本語わかるって言っているしは操作も
さあもう結局口だけば[ __ ] google 翻訳家ら何でも使ってもいいかなぁ
サーフ
俺が言ってることを理解できるのかなっていうまあそういう実験動画みたいな感じです
これも一応実験動画だから方姫もたくさん飲んでもすでに飲み過ぎて手を見過ぎてっ
もっともっとこのような動画を作りたいなぁ結構前から思ってるんですよね思ってるん
ですけれどもなかなかなんだろうまあ女医さんが山女医がさっき言ったように自分の
視聴者たちはもう1本もイギリス阻害する6っきり
を阻害するって言う自信がないからじゃなくてまあ彼の日本語の評価ですよねあいき
ましたマグロックを好きなキーホルダーです
なんかかわいいフサフサだし幼稚園の頃にもうトトロを見てまして
井本ずっと見てたんですよずっとファンではいみなさん気づきましたか
僕の日本語へたくそです最初に空に飛んでいくシーンあるじゃないですかあのシーンで
絶対もう一緒に音をやってたんですよもう何回も何回も
なんかー面白かったんですかねはいまぁここまで聞いたらタウンへ
気づいている方はいると思うんですよねそうなんです
金は要らない外来語をほとんど使っていませんっていうのはで彼の日本語
彼の日本の半分以上はまだ純粋な日本語のままですこれは a ためですジョイ
現在現代現在わかりますね
ない日本語の半分以上は8外来語ですよ
所いいアドバイスハンドバイス分かります日本語を話すときは英語が完璧に話せること
をアピールしながら話してくださ不自然の英語に聞こえる日本語にしてくださいつまり
日本語ではなく
japanese 10年前なら場合もん
完璧ですが今ではもうあ男のジェネレーションの日本語は
だから本当にパーフェクトな日本語を目指すならもっといい棒を使ってくださいあとは
あとはもう完璧です相次ぎの方へ行きたいと思います以上ですジョイ豪華さです次の方
はこちらの方です
クリスプラーナパワーレンジャーかなり今有名に
あって結構前から有名になってるんだよねプレスん初めて僕は姉と日本であった
越冬 youtube 持って
友達というか youtube をやっている方です動画が1本しかない状態でね僕と
一緒に動画を作ってくださいっていうのはおかしいから
校別の youtube やってる人たちに連絡する前に僕はちょっとしたストックを
作ろうと思ったんですよね
からまぁ半年かけて youtube 終えがー
貼った後でこの a 方9エスパー僕の友達のクリスパーに
えっと連絡してみた一緒に動画を作りませんか
僕実はのゲイバーギンとかあんまり好きじゃないんですよねで彼は全然ず j バージン
じゃなくてえっと
本当に何だろう
ちっちゃい映画をこう1個ずつ作ってるっていうのがボクスン刻す綺麗で彼はと普段
から英語で動画を作ってるんですけれども有名で日本で動画を作ってるから
彼は日本語ってできるのかなって思ってる方が多いみたいなんですよね
彼が動画を高透過するたんび
2日本語で動画を作ってくださいとかっていうコメントが結構あるんですよねなんで
評価してみたいと思います
質問自己紹介強いだろう
あなたこそあのじゃあ油脂の周してるんですか6年間くらい日本にずっと続けました
あの今仙台に住んで
受注といいでしょう
よろしくお願いますよ youtube という仕事をしています
うらやまし
僕は辺ちゃんという仕事をしています tb ex 普及度オプション
駅舎ぴょんとしちゃいまいないこれはない
現在あの良俗リストと申します
いらっしゃいます
rar
なんて呼べばいいですか
クルシュはいここで評価を始めたいと思います
彼のバッ僕の場合は8日本がもう13歳ぐらいのときからずっと勉強してきてるんです
よねずっと勉強してるって言うのに全然文法が合ってないし全然人前では絶対 a もう
全く話せないから全然
にダメですけど彼の場合はけっこうすごいと思うんですよねっていうのは彼が大学確か
同大学卒業したあとで日本に来たんですよね
大学卒業したあとで日本に来たというのに彼と日本語を話すときは
彼と一緒に日本語を話すときは全然違和感を得感じないというかもうちょっと日本語
あるんだな
この動画とってくれを違いは
仙台と言いましたよ
有名な食べ物は何ですか
もちろん k ちゃん
牛タンですほしいですねうん
主観回だが週1回
すごいちょっとネットかあのリセッで2000円ぐらい
高いねまぁこんな感じで a 彼が日本語をしゃべってるときは全然普通に聞こえ
聞き取れる子なんだろう聞き取りやすい日本語なってると思うんですねこれの日本語は
僕の場合は結構
ちっちゃい時から勉強してるんですけれどもかなり発音のことを意識こしながら話す
から逆に意識しすぎて言葉が出てこないというケースが結構ある時って言う
こんな感じです
なる村大会に参加しますかいえまだ決めていません
申し込みはさてまでですよはいわかりました
[音楽]
ni
alejandro me forever with voice とパーティルー
ドゥローンベーターんだー web オンペっていうことはあ嘘です
[音楽]
ジャーナル紙の大会に参加するかどうか原さん退院方参加するかといえば着替えてい
ません
もし米はあさってまでですよ
はいわかりましたは can
結構テレビ出演とかもう捨てるから普通に凄いと思うんですよね僕はできないんですよ
ね
誰もいない空間の中でしかはれ日本語話せないから
ファーレロスター
ことわざ
腐るでも木から落ちる
んですか哀悼ねはいどうぞいうか
ネ実は分かりません
ホント
ことはいいあの蜜骨の形でぞ
hr アップフリース雨降って地固まる前に打たずケリー
ic しょんぐ雨降ってへ
鹿と思える俺も知らんわ俺も知らうん彼の日本語に関しては実はあんまりこう
直すところがないというかすごく話しやすい相手になってるから
いいと思うんですよねすごくただし彼のもう一つの動画みてわかったことなんだけど
腕の血管があんまり出てないみたいなんだよね
えっ
醍醐ウォッチ
リビングライフ
ていうか4んじゃ伺いキラーともう夕飯をすくえありー
日本人女性にモテたいならやっぱりこう
出てる方がモテるみたいだから腕の血管がもっと見えるように頑張ってくださいスター
も完璧です合格ですああああ具材
たーーーーーーーッッッッッッでもええ時間がないんでもっともっとたくさんの人の
日本語
聞きたかったんですけども時間がないんで次回にしたいと思います
はい次回ははえもー pbr とか per 村とかえミストやバトンとか
ウィチョンジュンとかまぁ midi 村とか最近になって話題になったに b デー
ションっとか皆さん
公共の
動画どうでしたかいいかがでしたか僕はもう
普段絶対動画で台本を使って動画を作るから
みなさんがこの動画見てどうもかっていうのが好きになるっていうかいいえ
こういう動画作ったことないからうーんどうなんだろう
ni